foreign
[Music]
dude I have new dates I have new dates
out new dates just announced and this is
uh first of all you know about the uh
Columbus and Cincinnati and Ohio and
Boise and so like I added Tucson and
Pueblo Colorado and Colorado Springs
Colorado but then also just now I added
on the Don't Push Me Tour Charlotte
Knoxville Little Rock Arkansas man he's
going down South Nashville Tennessee oh
bringing a guitar uh Calgary Edmonton
Ottawa for my Canadian people Montreal
okay so it's not Toronto this is what
they told me it's Toronto proper it's
like 30 minutes away it's Hamilton
Ontario at the first Ontario Concert
Hall I'm gonna try and come to also
Toronto the actual City next year but I
couldn't get dude you guys get mad at me
for dates but that I can't do it these
are all booked up there's like a million
touring people you know I gotta like
battle with like Morgan Wallen or
whatever is Wallen or Waylon whatever
he's good Cleveland Ohio I am doing
Cleveland Detroit people keep asking me
Orlando Fort Myers
um Fort Myers Florida and I'm also
adding more so uh I am adding more soon
and I told you I got other dates coming
I know people really want Vancouver
Vancouver's so booked up I'm trying to
find a spot to get there have something
on hold it's coming I'm not forgetting
about you especially if you're a big
city but don't push me towards coming so
anyway without further Ado welcome to
the next episode of congratulations
[Music]
nice oh wow already messed it up wow
thought I was gonna put the thing on the
right thing but it didn't do the thing
oh yeah I want it on the left one wow
okay so now I'm stupid messed it up
twice I got the uh
there we go dude hair's looking night
I'm not gonna lie my hair's looking nice
dude look at that it's like fluffy it's
like nicest
it's really good man so you know yeah I
got a big forehead but that's what's up
uh means I'm smart dude
um
I I just I've had a great week I've had
a very busy week
um I'm really happy that you guys are
here and thank you for listening like
And subscribe uh and uh merch
crystallia.com but whatever dude
uh leave a comment pump that algorithm
let me know where you're coming to see
me if there's people coming I just
announced all my new new tour dates
um
and uh yeah but dude uh I have been uh
really really really grateful I did
shows let's just get right into it I did
shows Monday Tuesday Wednesday in uh
Irvine Brea Oxnard
to nail down exactly what I wanted to do
in my hour special taping
um flew figured that out flew to
um
Milwaukee every time I hear Milwaukee I
think Milwaukee and I thought that was
me but then I realized that that's the
actual Indian way to pronounce it
uh so I must have heard it somewhere or
I'm I'm the psychic Indian
um
so yeah so Milwaukee and then did the
last show
oh it's from Wayne's World Milwaukee
that's why Wayne's World dude
wow uh one Fire coming through dude with
that with that Wayne's World thing
that's why I got dude how can you think
how could you hear something when you're
12 and then just think it when you're 43
and then you're like why did I think
that
and then it's just Mike Myers with a wig
on 40 years ago
um you know you heard it twice because
you saw it once and then you saw it
again for your friend's birthday party
and you had to sit through it twice
um that in Ghostbusters too Vigo scared
the [__] out of me um so anyway but yeah
so uh
so anyway uh uh I did the Milwaukee
show and then I flew to
Minneapolis to do the taping now
I was actually a bit nervous
I wasn't
nervous like scared I was more anxious
but also a little bit nervous actually
you know what I was scared for a reason
because I there was a storm people kept
saying like there's a storm there was no
storm but they kept saying there was a
storm so I was like oh am I gonna make
it the flight got delayed and my one of
my buddies was gonna come out the day
before their whole flight got canceled
there was no flight that they could make
it and they were in LA
so I was like oh no
if they're in LA and we're coming from
Milwaukee that's the same direction I
believe I don't know really I'm not good
with directions but I was like Zara's
gonna get canceled ours got delayed and
we're like should we drive from
Milwaukee to Minnesota we did not do
that we waited for the flight got on a
flight landed and then I couldn't even
take a nap I was like if I had four
hours of sleep
um
did the special
and
I was
so
um
ready I mean I'm ready you know and I
also I've only been performing this hour
for
eight months like I did it it was a year
so I worked I work at the clubs a little
bit to try and get new material
like it was 2021 I started doing it in
like September I would go up every now
and then with minimal material then
April came along and I booked a date in
Phoenix one of my favorite spots to do
um
and it was April 30th and then so a year
later I did
um what do you call it I did uh that I
started the I did the taping so besides
that
um it was
I took from April to like August off so
it was really from August to now I I I
was doing the tour and that's a very
short time actually from
when I uh start performing to to
shooting a special it's usually like a
year or or more you know man on fire I
was touring it for so long I was so sick
of it but I didn't want to
I didn't want to do it too here's the
deal when I do the tour I don't know
when this is going to come out but when
the special comes out it
um
it comes out and uh I'll I will have
to have some new material so in essence
when I when I shoot to special I have to
then think about starting new material
Because by the time it comes out I want
to have new material and I don't want
people to who have seen this special to
see everything from the special some
Comics do that and they are lazy but I
don't want to do that I don't feel good
about myself doing that I also am bored
with the material after I do it but this
hour is so special to me
um it it it just is um it's not just
funny you know I'm speaking a lot of
stuff from the heart
um and so I was a little nervous about
shooting that because I wanted it I
wanted to really connect with that
emotionally and it's also
um not something that I usually do like
when I first did my specials I just was
like I just want to be funny I don't
care you know people always like you
know yeah but what are you really
talking about it's like I'm talking
about how messed up and silly everything
is but this is this special is way
different from my my uh you know it's me
growing and it's me uh getting out there
and and and now I'm I'm now I'm in my
40s my last special I did it when I was
39 and um yeah so I don't know it's just
it went off the first special the first
taping we did it twice the first taping
was great the second one was just one of
the best
times I did that hour so it really uh it
really means a lot that you guys came
out in Minneapolis I I love you guys I
love the support that I get uh that
everybody came out on the tour
so far I'm still doing the Don't Push Me
Tour because it hasn't come out yet the
special but like
um I just so appreciate you and this is
what I wanted to start out with this
podcast but I so appreciate you coming
through and so appreciate you supporting
me
um and I just I can't thank you enough
for for for that I really can't
um watching this the the
the Vlogs and the tour reports which I
put out there and just uh being a part
of it really genuinely means the world
to me and I know I talk a lot about you
know silly stuff on this podcast but uh
that's that's what's up and uh I really
I am so fortunate and thankful that you
guys come out to see me and I love you
for it and I try to always give you guys
the best show that I possibly can uh
which is also why I have to I have to
start writing new material now again but
yeah I love it anyway dude uh let's be
silly you know I know I know I know you
like also when I'm when I'm transparent
and all that stuff but let's be silly
too
um I don't have a title yet I I'm
circling on what the titles are will
might maybe be uh but I don't know and
when I drop it I drop the trailer it's
gonna go gangbusters we go your boys
gonna go dummy viral so we'll drop the
title then you know what I mean okay
anyway stop the cap
um I don't know what the [__] one one
fire added a bunch of things dude I went
to go I went to go uh I went to go put
on you know Matt my buddy Matt Rife hit
me up and he was like yo we post about
my special and I was like [__] yeah
let's do this the dude's awesome and I
and I posted on the thing and I went to
go click the link on that story to
connect it and I copied his I copied his
YouTube link to put on my story and I
posted it and then when I posted it
after I posted it the link was a
different link and I was like what the
[__] it is because my producer was on my
computer he had already copied the link
since I copied the link from that Rife
and put it on the thing and it was a
video where the guy goes stop the cat
and so that was the link that was
everybody was
see and when I did the Matt right thing
so anyway
go watch his special it's great he's
awesome he's uh exploded on the comedy
scene but uh it's great it's out there
now it's called Matthew Stephen Rife
it's the whitest name I've ever heard in
my life but also he is uh exploded so go
check his [__] out he's great
um anyway dude you know let's get into
it dude
let's get into it he added a bunch of
different uh things on my on my sound
sound board but that's that's cool dude
how about this man
um Kanye loves the Jews again
who knew ah
and thank God for 21 Jump Street because
that's what he saw you do it he watched
so he's mental he's manso man
and it's just like okay he loves it he
first of all he didn't hate the Jews he
thought he hated the Jews right that's
what he thought he thought that he's
mentally unstable and you want to be
like well [__] it you know it's sad is
mentally unstable but then then you go
like this well you know what Hitler was
unstable and mentally unstable so then
there we go everyone in the Third Reich
was unstable and mentally imbalanced so
okay so then it's like at what point
does it it does it you know you want to
you want to give Grace to people who are
mentally unwell but then also you don't
want to give too much grace because they
end up you know being Hitler also so
it's like
you know Kanye kept doubling it out and
doubling down kept doubling down until
they killed me and uh but they kept
doubling down and then all of a sudden
Adidas was like no or if you're a dork
you could say Adidas
um you go all right well Kanye you know
it's too it's too bad I really liked
your sneakers but you can't thank you
for working for us but then you gotta go
so then it's like Adidas was like oh
wait a minute we lost 1.6 billion
dollars we fired Kanye and it's like
maybe we should re-hire Kanye
you know what I'm saying and yes what he
said was bad but also we want that 1.6
billion dollars back again
so what happened was they are talking
about rehiring him and because of that
he watched 21 Jump Street and said
because Jonah Hill is in it and did a
good job and he's funny that he doesn't
hate Jews anymore and I'm just sitting
there like
huh more disrespectful do you know what
I mean and I'm just sitting there like
okay well it was disrespectful that he
hated that he was saying he hated the
juice but now he lie the reason why he's
come around on it is because Jonah
Hill's performance in 21 Jump Street huh
that's even more disrespectful to see
Jonah Hill running around and pretending
like he's a cop in high school and then
Kanye West goes like this you know what
on second thought
June should be more mad at that that's
what turned him around
and he's got the post up he's got it on
Instagram and it's the only post up on
it on his Instagram feed and it's just
like
that's more disrespectful
um so anyway now Adidas is just like
yeah we don't give a [__] however he
wants to say he likes it again that's
okay let's get the 1.9 there's only 1.6
billion dollars in
so anyway
Kanye loves the Jews again so now we can
chill dude this could be the point where
the world gets back on track since the
pandemic everything's gonna [__] this
can be the point where it goes back on
track let's just make it with the point
go back on track you know we had Trump
everyone hated Trump you know the it
seemed like everyone hated Trump didn't
really because look you gotta like it
then we have Biden everyone hated Biden
seems like everyone hate about it but
you know a lot of people love Biden so
it's like let's get into president
that's going to get in here and do some
[__] damage right it's all gone to
[__] and Kanye West loves the Jews now
so let's just get it let's just
everything's better right guys
um
what did he actually write on the thing
Kanye West
Jonah Hill
uh he writes
oh God they say Seth Rogen reacts to
Kanye West saving Jonah Hill's saying
Jonah Hill Seth Rogen you know
you know
what did he say here
yay on gay on Instagram
this is what he says if you haven't
heard which is crazy if you haven't
heard watching Jonah Hill in 21 Jump
Street made me like Jewish people again
it's straight to the point
uh no one should take anger against one
or two individuals and transform that
into hatred toward millions of innocent
people no Christian can be labeled
anti-semite uh knowing Jesus is Jew
thank you Jonah Hill I love you you know
and then he just and then he and then
somebody just writes under that w
though the internet you know
dude that's a that's a w comment I want
people right yo that's an L comment
that's a l
yo dude that's l
so congratulations to the Kanye West and
honestly congratulations to the Jews
because he's got he's got that back on
he's got that back on
is Trump arraigned has been arraigned no
he's not been arraigned right but he
will be tomorrow so this will be coming
out the next day so let's just pretend
dude how about that Trump [__] dude it's
crazy he's gonna be arraigned he's never
gonna go to jail so everyone just if he
goes to jail by the way
do you understand how many [__] up
things are going to happen so let's just
hope maybe he'll just like he's older
right he's like he'll pass away I don't
know and I'm not even saying I don't
don't come at me like I'm a Trumper or
an anti-trumper I'm neither
I don't give a [__] you know what I do
silent you know how people say silence
is violent that's me then I guess
I'm a violent guy then
says when the [__] is silence violence I
don't like that you know I don't like
that [__]
um
so anyway dude
it's just
it's just like
oh I forgot the [__] thing though
about the
on the um
man I tell you what dude when you travel
a lot
it is
you really get a representation of what
the [__] America is like I mean I went
to Milwaukee and when I got on the plane
to Milwaukee I I mean dude everything is
so insane everything is so insane I got
to the airport we got on the plane I got
on the plane and I'm bored on the plane
because the plane because it sucks right
and there was no TV I think in it it was
like I wanna every time they get a plane
that was from 1978 so I got a DM the top
DM I go check it I look it says hey
don't worry bro your bag is safe
and I look at the image and it's a
picture of my bag on the [__] in the
plane
like the the guy who puts the bags in
the thing took a pic of my thing and
then sent it to me like some [__] and
I'm just like a dude
that's one of those things that's like
it's like that's creepy tell me more
about that but it's like you get scared
but like for what reason it's just a
picture of a bag but also you know not
to be creepy on an airplane dude
the guy sends me a picture of my own bag
that's creepy tell me more about that
it's insane and so I'm like Jesus and I
screenshot I said that to my whole team
who's you know in the plane they go yo
you should report this guy's like I
don't want to get anybody fired
he's like you want me to report it I'm
like no no chill dude because my uh
my tour manager's gangster dude
he's like let me report it I'll report
it I'm like no dude just chill
and I'm like well this guy's just
[__] right here's the [__] up thing
everybody
has your phone number basically
like you can contact anyone anyway from
the phone
you can talk you want you want to talk
to Elon Musk you basically have his
phone number
DM
I mean guess what he'll get it that's so
[__] up how connected we are
that now I got the the the the the
United Airlines [__] guy who checks
in the he's not even dude he's not even
the guy the person who checks the bag
and he was like the the troglodyte under
the thing near the conveyor belt that
was like
with it you know what I mean with this
[__] uh
Android
send
because you saw my name on the bag
that's so [__] creepy dude I'm just
like that's creepy tell me more about
that that's creepy tell me more about
that
and so I'm on the plane
and somebody walks by and they're I'm
already in the seat you know and
somebody walks by crystally I'm a huge
fan great dude
now I gotta beat me the whole flight
everyone's gonna be knowing I'm on it I
go in incognied I got the hood up I sit
down somebody walks by Chris Delia
you're a dude I'm a big fan and I'm just
like
dude
I'm just sitting there like no I gotta
[__] be me the whole time
it's okay I appreciate the love I really
do dude
[Music]
listen guys when it comes to saving
money as a small business owner every
little bit helps ship station gives you
access to discounts of up to 84 of USPS
and UPS rates and you can manage every
order from one simple to use dashboard
when you lower your shipping costs and
make returns easy your customers can
stay happy while you save money
Hey listen running merch can be
stressful of course no doubt but having
ships stationed in our Corner makes
everything easier with their dashboard
I'm telling you if you're a small
business owner this is the thing to get
ship station hooks you up with
industry-leading discounts so you'll
never have to worry about paying for
shipping get up to 84 of USPS and UPS
rates and if that's not enough use my
promo code to try shipstation for two
free uh free for two months I look over
a hundred thousand a hundred and thirty
thousand companies have grown for their
e-commerce businesses with ship station
and so get involved man you don't be
left out worry less about the bottom
line when you save money with ship
station go to shipstation.com and use
code congrats today and sign up for your
free 60-day trial that's shipstation.com
code congrats
crazy crazy
and so I [__] we fly
bro let me tell you this man we're in
the we're on the plane we land and you
know
you're not supposed to get up until they
stop moving the plane
obviously and they always land and then
you know we we touch down and then you
always stop
and then after you stop you're not
you're still not right you're not there
you know
the planet the pilots always like
yeah so where you got it you know or
it's fourth in line to get to the thing
and you're just like okay you know and
then so
we land
and we as soon as we land
the the somebody comes barreling down
the [__] uh aisle and I'm like oh
that's it for me because that's the
thing too I'm like oh we're good because
like you know this is gonna be a
terrorist attack and also
here's the thing about terrorist attack
if I was a gangster terrorist if I was a
a gangster [__] terrorist like
a real real hardcore you I would wait
till the whole flight till they landed
and then and then
took over because here's why because you
really want to terrorize someone have
the last thing they do in their life be
a four-hour flight
is always like all right we're up in the
air let's do it dude [__] all that
have them go the whole flight and have
to eat [__] peanuts you know what I
mean in a half cooked chicken if they're
in the first class and then and and
right and you're in the flight have them
have them have to watch [__] Mickey
blue eyes
right I guess I'll watch this that's the
last thing you're sitting like this
watching [__] Hugh Grant be like
forget about it
that's that's a real terrorist you don't
do it when it gets up in here all right
all right [__] let's go you
wait till they almost land or land and
then say okay guys guess what
we're flying into the [__] the the
the
Potomac or whatever
or Lake Michigan we're flying in the
Lake Erie here we go ah it'd be like why
did you do it earlier because I'm a real
[__] G terrorist dude that's
why so the lady comes barreling up
really big lady with pink hair
all right
and she said and and the the flight
attendant is literally she didn't say
anything just to fight then just goes
like this she literally goes like this
like man
you person or what
hey ma'am you ever been somewhere
and the lady goes like this to the
flight attendant as we're still taxiing
hardcore like like we we're landing and
we're moving dude it's like do they go
like this and then the
passenger goes like this ma'am I'm going
to diarrhea right now
dude
she says ma'am I'm going to have to
diarrhea right now so loud as loud as
the person who walked by and said
Chrisley I'm a huge fan so now I'm like
whoa that is so gangster and that is the
real terrorist
so she the the flight attendant goes
like this okay the lady goes in the
thing just drops hardcore [__] and and
the most gangster thing is
she got out of the toilet before
everyone got off the plane she didn't
give a [__] about being embarrassed just
no shame in it was app was the best
she gets out she says first one ma'am
I'm going to diarrhea right now gets in
the thing gets out everyone's like oh
[__] pink hair dude older lady walks
back to her seat
then we taxi to the door then she gets
up gets out and I get right behind her
and she's going so slow and blocking
everything and I'm just like dude
diarrhea ring is one thing but making me
have to [__] hey move
but I was like gangster in the no shame
man I aspire to have that no shame
um which is cool you know it's like
here's the other thing too if I wasn't
famous I would be diarying everywhere
and telling everybody about it but I'm
famous so like I don't even care people
really know I'm diarrhearing places but
it's annoying if like someone gets a
picture and it's like yo Chrisley is
diarrhea in there it smells like [__]
and then I gotta
and I gotta deal with everybody online
like yo Chrisley a diarrhea I don't even
really give a [__] about that but also
it's annoying that then people will be
like
everybody diarrheas you know
whatever it my whole point is that lady
more people should be like that lady but
also
dude and then David Sullivan had to do
it and he was like man man I was when we
went to we flew in somewhere else and he
was like man oh back to LA it was like I
was almost gonna do that lady did man I
had to go because I ate steak last night
and then drank a coffee this morning
um
yeah
so that was just amazing I love it but
you really get a taste when you're when
you're when you're traveling how it
literally insane everyone is
but before the flight was even over this
uh young woman was sitting in front of
me and she was like she goes to the bat
this whole thing is everything around
the bathroom but she's goes to the
bathroom and
before she goes to the bathroom well no
she goes to the bathroom she gets up
walks out before she gets into the
bathroom uh we're first we're like Row
three so
the bathroom is very close before she
even gets it about them her alarm goes
off bro I was this was the mo for some
reason this really earthy her alarm goes
off
and very loud at the LA I didn't even
know the alarms go that I thought here's
the deal I didn't know alarms go that
loud on the iPhone because I don't put
mine at the full blast obviously
nothing's happening if you need your
alarm to go off when you're waking up
nothing's making a sound anyway so don't
make it the loudest [__] if you're
somebody who puts the alarm full blast
you're kind of a piece of [__] if you
live with someone okay and you know I
live with someone right so
uh I am doing I am I am on the plane
this lady gets up and before she gets to
the bathroom her alarm goes off just
pam pam pam pam pam pam you know that
one pam pam pam pam just so horrible
okay and I'm like oh good before she got
to the bathroom so she'll hear it come
back turn it off
planned Pap so I'm she that's what she
does
gets in the [__] [__] so I'm like
oh are you she doesn't hear it
because it's so loud all right
does a whole [__] in the bathroom or
piss I don't know maybe sometimes ladies
take a long time to piss because you got
to sit down just the whole time pam pam
pam pam just I mean three minutes of
this is happening
and I'm sitting there like look I could
reach in front of me turn the thing off
but guess what I don't do
I don't touch other people's [__]
I'm not gonna touch someone's phone I
don't care if the flight attendant wants
to come by and touch someone's phone and
turn it off fun and also if it bothered
me that much I would touch the phone but
it didn't really bother me that much and
I know it's gonna end as soon as the
letter comes out so I'm chilling dude I
make all these decisions pretty quickly
uh it takes three minutes anyway the
whole thing happens for three minutes
this is that doesn't bother me that much
okay what happened with that lady
doesn't bother me that much doesn't
really bother me that the sound is
happening flying is annoying anyway this
is the worst part dude the lady next to
me who the whole flight has been
this
every
like every 30 seconds and dude it's one
of those things that you don't realize
happening and then once you do
once you do
okay
catch you later man
I mean I was getting so livid
so the lady who's sniffing next to me I
was like pam pam pam
pam pam like she the sniffer turns to me
okay I'm on my phone
texting people
she turns to me and says
is that your phone
[Music]
hey dude three minutes in
is that your phone
ah
hey ma'am
get a clue
dude I'm I'm on my and I'm by the way
I'm doing this I'm doing this is what
I'm doing
oh I'm far out oh man pam pam oh dude
nobody's in this seat in front of me
[__] dude so many [__] things are
wrong with this first of all
why would I wait that long
okay
but even further before that
why would she wait that long
to ask me so
she's at fault for
more than I
it's not my phone okay but also if she's
waiting that long to ask me
is that your phone
that she's at fault here if she thinks
maybe it's my phone she should have said
something already three minutes is that
my phone dude also snot my phone you
know why I'm not deaf also I'm on my
phone
looking at my phone
I'm also looking around like oh wow I'm
looking at people she says is that your
phone and I look at her and I laugh
I say and I say I love I say I said is
that my phone
I repeat what she says and I say if this
was my phone I would turn it off
hey lady
get a clue hey lady you've been
somewhere
dude it drove me that was I was so after
that I really got to work on my anger
dude I was so angry
because
why was I even angry dude
like what was I angry about
I was an angry she I was not angry that
she would think maybe it was my phone
because of Any shortcomings for me like
I'm angry that she's that much of an
idiot that's what I was angry about
but it can't be that I have to see
something myself there that's on me
obviously
but like what the [__] is that your
phone
what if I said yeah
I wish I said yeah should have been like
oh well why don't you turn it off and
then
Oh I thought it was nice and melodic
like what the [__]
people are nuts dude such a slice of
America
wow that would be a [__] Ed Burns
movie in 2001.
slice of America starring Ed Burns and
the [__] whoever that young girl was
in the in the show 24.
starring Ed Burns and Eliza Dushku
slice of America
only white people are in it
dude
um
hey
douche kill
man we were in a we went to um you know
Mars pregnant this year she's about 11
months pregnant and uh I mean her tummy
is so
so big and she's so many but her tummy's
so big
and dude she's gonna I mean we're gonna
have this kid in like a week you know
and
um
we go to we
the second the day I fly out
I'm on the plane and she's like ah it's
kind of funny but I think maybe my water
might have broken I go like this okay
so
this is difficult so don't be so typical
and also
is it life that's [__] with me or is
it you that's [__] me something's
going on here your water's not breaking
because I need to do this special and
I'm gonna have to fly home and cancel it
if my son comes
so I say
all right well keep it in check if you
start having contractions okay she's
like well I'm having Braxton Hicks
contractions I'm like ah don't talk to
me about things that I have no idea
about
is it time to go to the goddamn hospital
or not you know what I mean so
and uh
so
I fly back
and we have an appointment on Monday
I fly back Sunday we're gonna put it on
Monday we go to the
um
doctor and check the thing Dr Jackson
and everything bleep it out and uh
and we and she
she's like good great looks good and my
wife says you know I was worried that
maybe my water broke five days ago and
here I am just like
don't even bring it out
you know they're gonna do all sorts of
[__] tests now like just [__]
done I'm bringing it up she had like a
little she's like but I've been kind of
leaking and I'm like yeah but yeah but
and I'm in my head I'm and I say I'm
like it could be just pissed though
right like [__] so uncouth in the
doctor's office sweetie is it pissed
though because the baby's head's on your
bladder upside down right he's hitting
your bladder and you could just be going
piss
and the doctor's like well it could be
piss but urine she said it could be
urine but you know what there are
instances where the sack your water will
break and it will be a very tiny leak
and so we should go get it checked out
in the hospital and and I'm like oh well
when she's like now and I'm like
great so now it's the thing okay so
we're gonna go to the hospital and I'm
okay about it because I want to take
care of my sweetheart right
am I on board
um but also I don't I know it's I know
it's PP you know what I'm talking about
the baby's upside down pushing on your
bladder and you're going baby
so um
we we leave and my wife well I couldn't
believe my wife was like let's eat lunch
first I was like wow okay cool because
you know if there's a tear in the in the
set you gotta have the baby you gotta
have the baby you no matter how little
the tear is you got to go have the baby
immediately so they're gonna go to the
hospital you test for the big for the
sack to if it open and then we'll sit
there and we'll have the baby if not we
go home false alarm
so we go we have lunch and then we go to
the [__] hospital and uh
we get in there
and like you know the doctor comes in
checks her bleep it out and uh you know
it's like an old lady I didn't know that
by the way they I forgot I guess I went
I guess I've had a kid before so I
didn't know that but the the nurse just
comes in and just goes like ah let's
check it out oh that's the noise right
there that's the noise on the plane
so loud though how long does it go
all right the thing oh now it's snoozing
[__]
dude and that's crazy that went off
so
so we the the lady comes in checks her
and she's like tested it all good and I
go I knew it was pissed the whole time
dude
I knew it was pissed off but good but
I'm acting like I didn't no it was
pissed hold on because I'm not an MD I
get up I'm like yeah okay it was great
great congratulations it was pissed
or other kind of stuff that just leaks
out you know the body's going through
all sorts of [__]
and uh
and so then uh we get the lady is like
do we have to check the uh cervix cervix
is that what's called yeah the lid comes
in checks it again goes puts her whole
hand in there like my like my wife is
like a sock puppet and then uh and then
checks it and the lady is like yeah the
cervix is soft but it's not dilated so
you guys can go home so we go home
and that was that man but it's just like
it's like I I can't wait to have this
baby we have a feeling we know what it
was going to be named but he's gotta be
it Calvin it's been great so this Baby's
gonna come out with like [__] A Guy
Fieri shirt on you know and just be like
so he's gonna put us through the ringer
hey how about how Ronaldo has a 9
million dollar Bugatti Cristiano Ronaldo
shows off his nine new nine million
dollar Bugatti hey
hey
what's in it
bacon
do you know what I mean uh the inside is
made of bacon the inside is made of
bacon and chocolate but it's the
chocolate it's the bacon from the pigs
that are only in this one area and they
had to ship them in what's in it
nine million dollars
what
well and the license plate is on the
[__] left side so shitty you know how
it looks God I look so shitty
it looks so shitty this car is so shitty
you know
wow there's only 10 in the world and he
has number seven of course because he's
number seven I guess
nine million imagine driving a 9 million
dollar car you just I mean imagine
valeting it
hey hey uh because some [__] would
still be like no you can't park yourself
you'll be like yo this [__] thing is
nine million dollars man there's only 10
of them
it doesn't matter you sure it's not a
million dollars get that shitty license
plate on the left side of it looks
really [__] stupid
you know so [__] Italian
Bugatti spaghetti marinara
Bugatti purushuto
it's a prosciutto spaghetti marinara
that's what the car is
this is [__] unreal dude imagine it
being like yeah yeah give me the 9
million dollar one
[__] my wife would ding it you know my
wife would ding it coming in [__] I hit
the gate for [__] sake the gate
spinner it's not don't okay but don't
somehow I'd still be a fault
my wife I I think something happened to
the Bugatti Ventimiglia
what happened I I don't know what do you
mean you don't know did it it made a
noise it made a noise or the [__] you
scraped it I don't know and then I look
and there's a huge scrape in the side
this is gonna cost me a million point
five to fix
it's because of the gate Nah The Gates
have been there
you shouldn't get me this car if this is
gonna be what's happening
don't yell it makes you know dude I
wanna how come I can't why can't we get
mad right [__] God damn it dude chicks
be turning on that crying [__] and then
you got you realize oh [__] I'm an
[__] duh [__] God damn it you know
what the [__] you go like that and they
go this is not a right way to react oh
I'm sorry that you crashed my car
it's hard not to be mad dude I gotta
[__] really relax I gotta piss so bad
we gotta take a break all right I'm back
let's watch this video here
of this guy who won't get off
uh
the plane
he's
all right let's this is crazy
the plane that's totally fine with no
pressure work and then then we'll get
you off okay I just dealt with the FBI I
know what I'm up against uh not the
thing to say right away listen I just
dealt with the FBI I know what I'm up
against at all I mean showing your hand
you know that you're a [__] fugitive
so this has nothing to do with the dog
it has to do with you for what okay
whatever they're complaining is right
now
it's just
they want you they want the dog on the
floor and that's against the wall okay
well dogs can go anywhere for the dog oh
the guy wants the dog on the seat dude
like wow okay what did I do okay because
I'm [__] sick and tired of
discrimination discrimination dude
unbelievable the thing is it's a private
entity here okay with federal funds
you're okay you guys are about to wow
dude
you guys are about to get so fine [__]
but they want you off the plane so not
again okay oh he just goes not getting
off dude you know people are so mad when
they don't even say I'm you know where
they're just like not getting off dude
that's so dick okay
well here's the thing look at the board
okay keyboard
could you imagine
wow the [__] voice over get up get
off
also who cares dude put on the ground
if I put them on the floor
then I'll stay can you tell them
so
[Music]
oh that's the worst bro this is America
dude so then he agreed to put the dog on
the ground right now that's what's
happening right
it's too late yeah
he said it's not America to Hawaii
a couple years ago
are those just pubes
been showing us his pubes you know in
the meantime
I got my five-year-old here you're a
great role model thank you oh wow and
you should listen to Eminem
so weird
that's rich hey guess what our country
is [__] anyway so thanks for Joe Biden
just trying to start a rally you know oh
yeah well guess what our country's
[__] anyway so thanks to Joe Biden
dude that's like a joke when people go
like great Biden's America because they
can't get their ketchup at a restaurant
please don't please don't even say
we got a comedian on the plane buddy
yeah it's just being funny well pretty
soon oh boy America's gonna be a police
so you just keep going ah dude getting
arrested you know
wow
I mean what the [__] bro well he's just
mentally it's
it makes it less funny if he's well no
God this guy had a lot he was totally
normal in 2019 you know and then in 2020
just [__] lost his mind when covet
hit this is totally a guy that lost his
mind when covet hit and you know what
sucks too the dogs like this because
he's got no shirt on
the guy isn't wearing a shirt
thank you thank you
[Music]
discrimination discrimination
discrimination
oh no oh my God I'm gonna go have a beer
and don't give a [__] about what you
guys say oh it's a bad English
freaking rest of the life
God doesn't know how it works I hope you
go to jail for the friggin rest of life
because he brought a dog on a plane and
won't get off the plane you know what
are you in here for murder what are you
in here for ah Biden's America
well guess what I was strangled at soja
so why don't you guys go [__] read
that
why don't you just go die because you're
not an American oh dude oh dude wow this
guy is so gangster why don't you just
die because you're not American man
doesn't mean a [__] eighth grade burn
you know
who's shooting this by the way the dog
he is
I haven't broken any [__] lies yet
okay
yet
dude it's a company you gotta go bro
you guys got no shirt on dude
I don't [__] touch me
no I'm not
oh I bet okay
I've got you guys on camera
I haven't broken Any Lies do you guys
want to read the Ada one
wow this guy holy [__] it's like [__]
seven of these [__] America this is a
you guys have discriminated more is that
Diplo this is [__] awesome dude I
would
I would
I thought the [__] Kawaii bus was bad
you know okay wherever wherever you go
it's bad you know
so
wow no shirt on just walking through the
airport
holding the camera so high too for some
reason
I mean why is the camera so [__] high
dude is it a drone does he is he
operating a drone
I mean how far does this shot go does it
go all the way for him to go into jail
foreign
he looks just being so defiant you know
being so [__] defiant for no reason
yeah what crime have I committed oh
yeah okay what can you tell me what
statue and why broke
all right well you need to tell me what
law I've broken oh
oh dude like doesn't understand how
business works
those are let's not get it twisted what
this isn't a service animal it's an
emotional support animal if you're a
blind man with actual oh yeah yeah of
course yeah dude that is crazy wow
Biden's America there you go dude
can't have a dog as a passenger Biden's
America
can't have a [__] dog the dog had
more clothes on than him dude the guy
had no shirt on on a plane could you
imagine how [__] annoying is
to be if you're somebody
are you on that plane
[Music]
sorry to bother you but we have to come
and tell you how much we really enjoyed
the show didn't we Garth
Anna this is Garth
with the Native Americans
in fact isn't Milwaukee an Indian name
yes Pete it is actually it's pronounced
miliwaki there we go that's that's what
I [__] knew that's what I got it from
Great
okay well whatever huh hey guys that's
it for YouTube if you want to catch the
the unedited version of this show go to
patreon.com crystalia and then you gotta
go to uh you get all you can get the
uncut unedited uh show and you can also
get the back episodes of congratulations
uh I think there's like 25 of them right
now I can get them all right now just
for six bucks so go to chrisley.com uh
or patreon sorry patreon.com
thanks guys
[Music]
okay
thank you
[Music]
foreign